faut savoir marcher au pas il faut
vraiment bien regarder aux alentours
faire attention à ceux qui sont devant
nous surtout ils sont près de 3000 de
son soldat rassemblés dans le camp de
satory à versailles pour les ultimes
répétitions du défilé du 14 juillet des
tirailleurs des hussards parachutistes
des aviateurs des marins et des
gendarmes
cette année les troupes américaines sont
à l'honneur pour marquer les 100 ans de
l'engagement des états unis d'amérique
dans la première guerre mondiale
145 militaires provenant de différentes
unités défileront devant le président
emmanuel macron et son invité le
président donald trump à leur tête cinq
militaires en uniforme authentique de la
première guerre mondiale
c'est vraiment un honneur d'être ici et
de commémorer notre histoire avec la
france
notre alliance nous travaillons ensemble
depuis tant d'années j'ai le privilège
de travailler avec les soldats français
c'est un grand honneur pour nous
les journées de répétitions s'enchaînent
pour les troupes à pied derniers
conseils dernier rappel pour ses 332
élèves de l'école polytechnique qui
portent licorne est épais chaque soldat
doit penser à régler c'est pas à
conserver ses distances exercice
rigoureux particulièrement pour les
élèves des écoles qui défilent pour la
première fois de la concentration est un
peu d'émotion pour ces élèves
infirmières de l'école de santé des
armées
ça se passe bien c'est quand même quand
même une expérience
exceptionnel on a juste le temps qui est
pas forcément avec nous tout le temps ou
pour ceux et celles de l'école de l'air
qui forment pilotes et officiers
mécaniciens
on est très bien très bien accompagné
avec des régulateurs qui nous aident à
à ajuster l'alignement à ajuster la
hauteur des bras sont des choses qui
sont très exigeantes puisque le jour j
il faut que tout soit parfait quand on
passera devant les tribunes juste une
pause et chacun reprend sa place une
dernière fois
il ne reste plus que quelques heures
avant le défilé sur l'avenue des champs
elysées devant toutes les autorités
les parisiens qui viendront les
applaudir et leur famille émue
[Musique]